hervé théry merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france le brésil est donc
le nouvel épicentre d'une copie de 19
alors comment peut-on l'expliquer est-ce
que c'est lié à un système de santé
défaillant est ce que c'est le résultat
d'une situation politique tendue où un
grand manque de moyens les trois îles et
rapport il ya deux systèmes de santé de
celui médecins qui viennent parler vient
d'un excellente hôpital einstein qui t'a
fait bon mais à côté de ça c'est un
service privé et à côté de ça il ya un
service public très défaillant une seat
est de masquer les paumés un système de
qualité les simplifier un peu mais
vraiment très très bon
pour aggraver sa les pouvoirs publics
tirent à hue et à dia et chacun fait ce
qu'il veut le gouvernement fédéral ni
l'importance de la vie d'amy et chacun
des états et sept soutien de son côté
donc c'est l'anarchie de direction là
aussi il ya les riches et les pauvres
des tarifs les états au donc tous à bout
tu as beau leurs équipements
insuffisants et l'absence de politique
est ce qu'il ya des régions qui sont
plus touchés que d'autres dans le pays
oui vous m'avez appelé j'étais comme
faire des cartes ou ce sujet
il apparaît nettement que la région la
plus pauvre le nordet ce qui est en
train d'avoir fortement et juste avant
on avait vu apparaître l'amazone est une
région très peu peuplée qui ne devrait
pas y avoir de problème sauf que les
jeunes habitent nous tous au bord des
fleuves et que le virus circule par les
bateaux on savait déjà qu'ils prenaient
l'avion entre la ville un peu trop
l'europe et l'afrique sur les routes est
maintenant sur les bateaux et donc il ya
vraiment des contagions qui se sont au
long des axes de transport vers les
régions pauvres de plus on voit de jour
en jour les quartiers peau il est carré
jaude souffrir de prison alors
l'assemblée des peuples indigènes du
brésil vous en parliez a été contrainte
d'annuler plusieurs rassemblements ces
peuples isolés sont ils aujourd'hui en
danger face au co vie de 19
oui mais pour une fois pas plus que nous
en fait il était depuis l'arrivée de
christophe colomb ils ont beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup souffert ils ont perdu
jusqu'à 90 % de leurs effectifs parce
qu'ils étaient il n'était pas immunisé
contre les maladies que nous nous avons
de nous sommes protégés au fil des
siècles
cette fois ci on est tous dans la même
situation qui sont au même régime que
les autres mais ils sont souvent un peu
plus fragiles s'ils sont dans leurs
réserves et qu'ils arrivent normalement
y z'ont entre que sur invitation
elle s'appelle et s'il ya des chercheurs
ou des entrées aussi font des allers
retours ils sont au même régime que doué
dont je pense que les défenseurs des
indiens profite de l'occasion pour
attirer l'attention c'est de bonne
guerre mais en l'occurrence y sont pas
spécialement plus menacés que les autres
voisines
parce que c'est vrai quand on aurait pu
imaginer que la barrière naturelle de la
forêt puisse protéger davantage ces
populations oui s'il était complètement
isolé dans la forêt mais c'est pas le
cas ils circulent en bateau ils ont
besoin de vendre et d'acheter et il se
visite entre eux c'est un fait une sorte
d'archipel simuler il ya des sortes de
village
ils sont loin les uns des autres mais
qui communiquent entre eux prix dont
canton il ya communication
s'il n'y a pas toutes les précautions
voulues suis leur situation est elle
préoccupante aujourd'hui la situation
s'est peuples indigènes
elle est toujours un peu mais assurent
les vingt dernières années la population
a nettement augmenté puisque justement
ils ont fini de me henri fini de
surmonter les maladies les plus
courantes et donc une veut construire
pas ceux qui sont dingues en amazonie ou
d'autres grandes réserves vont plutôt
mieux qu'avant la population augmente
ceux qui sont à proximité des villes et
sur des théâtres optiques une situation
très préoccupante il ya des choses
situation contrastée pour conclure dans
quel état d'esprit sont les brésiliens
aujourd'hui face à cette pandémie
ont très très inquiet vraiment on va
beaucoup de gens se faire des sources au
fait des soucis d'autant plus qu'ils
voient bien que beaucoup de gens ne
respectent absolument pas les règles de
séparation soit qu'ils sont partisans du
président qui nie l'épidémie soit qu'ils
soient tellement pauvres qu'ils doivent
sortir de toute façon vous gagnez au
jour le jour de quoi se nourrir et
nourrir leurs enfants
donc entre ceux qui refusent d'appliquer
leur confinement et ceux qui ne peuvent
pas la circulation du virus est très
forte les chiffres que vous avez donnée
sur les chiffres officiels ou pense que
c'est entre sept et dix fois plus irrité
le président jaillir bolzan arrow et
îles isolées aujourd'hui dans le pays
dans les sondages de ce matin dit ce
qu'il a sur son taux d'approbation son
taux de popularité dix minutes et il est
quand même encore à 30% des gens qui
sont à ces fanatiques autour de lui et
des gens qui l'ont élu pour refuser le
parti des travailleurs le parti de lula
et qui se décide pas à reconnaître une
bêtise on s'accroche on perd ça au
palace de thé jugé en gros il ya un
tiers de l'opinion derrière lui merci
beaucoup hervé théry d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
géographe et professeur à l'université
de sao paulo